One of these $100
bills is real,
and the other one is a piece
of prop money made for movies.
Can you tell which
one is which?
They both have a blue security
ribbon, textured ink,
and even the
smallest detail,
like text from the
Declaration of Independence.
The answer is obvious
when you flip them over.
Bills as detailed
as this one
are required to be blank
on the other side.
That's because
if prop makers,
like Prop Movie
Money in Florida,
print money that
looks too real,
they risk getting in trouble
with the US government.
That's what happened
20 years ago
on the set of "Rush Hour 2."
Gregg Bilson Jr.:
Money is more work
than it's worth,
in the long run.
Narrator: That's
Gregg Bilson Jr.,
CEO of the Los
Angeles-based ISS Props,
one of the biggest prop
houses in the world.
In 2000, Greg got an
order for and printed
$1 trillion of prop
money for "Rush Hour 2,"
most of which was going
to be blown up on screen.
And the prop money looks
good in this scene.
Too good, in fact.
Carter: Hello, Benjamin!
Narrator: The fake
money looked so real
that some extras on set
pocketed some of it
and tried to spend
it at real stores.
That alerted the
US Secret Service,
which confiscated and
destroyed the fake bills
and the digital files
used to print them.
It had cost $100,000 to print
all of that fake money,
so losing all of it
was a financial blow
to Gregg and ISS.
Bilson: We didn't try to make
fake money to dupe the public.
We made fake money
to make a movie.
But we just made
the prop too good.
Narrator: The "Rush Hour
2" incident underscored
an obvious dilemma for
printing fake money.
The money needs to look
realistic on camera,
but it can't look too
realistic up close,
or people might try to
spend it in real life.
The problem has become even
greater in recent years,
with better cameras capturing
more and more details
from the background
of scenes.
So the prop industry
has come up with
two different types
of prop money,
each with its own
strengths and weaknesses.
For scenes where the cash
is filmed from far away,
productions typically use
standard-grade bills.
The iconic money scene from
"Breaking Bad" uses these bills,
which were rented
from Gregg and ISS.
These bills look
real from afar,
but up close are
obviously fake,
with lots of
clear differences
when compared to
the real thing.
The portrait on the
bill is poor quality
compared to the real one.
And instead of "one
hundred dollars,"
it just reads "one hundred."
The smaller details on the
bill are also altered.
The seals are a
different design,
and the signatures on the
bill have been changed.
Then there are the
obvious additions,
like the prominently
displayed
"for motion
picture use only."
In fact, if you zoom in to this
scene from "Breaking Bad,"
while it's blurry,
you can actually see
that each bill says "for
motion picture use only."
These changes should keep
the Secret Service away,
but they also mean
standard fake bills
are no good for close-ups.
So for those shots, movies will
often use high-grade bills.
High-grade bills are
identical to real money
but are printed
on only one side
so that they can't be
confused with the real thing.
Like the one we
showed you earlier,
which was printed by
RJR Props in Atlanta.
You can see an example
of a high-grade bill
in this scene from the 2014
movie "Let's Be Cops."
An alternate solution
that Gregg and ISS
have been using for
the past several years
is to simply use real bills.
This is the first
version that they offer.
ISS will take a pile of
completely blank bill notes
and then place one real bill
on the top of the stack
and one on the bottom,
making it appear as
if the entire stack
is full of real bills.
The second method for
using real dollars
has a bigger risk attached,
but it may be the best option.
An entire stack
of real bills.
ISS will get stacks of
$10,000 from the bank
and then deliver
them to set.
While having this much
cash lying around
makes some
productions nervous,
it looks great on film
and eliminates any risk
with the Secret Service.
That's what they did in
this shot from "Ozark."
Bilson: I see fake money
used all the time,
and I think it is appalling,
because I'm a
property master,
and I want things
to be authentic
and accurate and look right.
Narrator: Take
a look at this
season one episode
of "Girlfriends."
The fake-looking money is
distracting to the audience.
While productions may
prefer to use real money,
sometimes it's unavoidable,
like in scenes where
bills are destroyed
or in scenes that require
an absurd quantity.
In cases like
these, Gregg says
that he will still
use fake money.
Except he certainly doesn't
print the fake money himself,
as he still has his
cease and desist
from the Secret Service.
So he buys it from
Prop Movie Money,
one of the few printers
that make prop money.
The ultimate irony of
printing prop money
is that it actually
isn't very profitable.
Standard and
high-grade bills
sell for roughly $45 for
a stack of 100 bills.
Gregg still has two
bills from "Rush Hour 2"
that the Secret Service
didn't confiscate.
Even though these bills
look less realistic
than modern prop bills,
he still has them
encased in plastic
so that no one can try to
use them in real life.
They're a physical reminder
of the risks prop makers take
and the rewards they reap to
get that perfect money shot.